العواقب ليست أسهل دائمًا،
هؤلاء هم رجال الإطفاء في المدينة الأكثر قصفًا
على وجه الأرض، أوريغون،
في خضم الهجوم المضاد،
وهذا يوم عادي بالنسبة لهم،
إليكم قصة شخص
تعرفنا عليه، ديما، شكرًا لك
أم
أجنبية
لا يأتي من النيران بعيدًا
عن الخطوط الأمامية فحسب،
تعاني أوكرانيا بطرق لا نراها، فقد
ديما جميع أفراد أسرته تقريبًا
منذ أن بدأت الحرب، وغادرت زوجته أوروبا
كلاجئة بعد أيام فقط من
بدء الحرب مع ابنه.  وهو لا يعرف
ما إذا كانوا سيعودون يومًا ما أم لا،
ففراغ منزل عائلتهم يمثل
عبئًا ثابتًا معوقًا عليه، وهو
أجنبي
أصعب من الرعب نفسه،
والنوم عندما يأتي يكون أحيانًا
أسوأ، فقد
أصبح الغرباء غبارًا في الماضي.  شهرين
ولكن حزن ديما هنا جاء مباشرة
مع غزو العام الماضي حيث
توفي والده في أيامه الأولى قبل أن
تغادر زوجته إثر نوبة قلبية يقول
بسبب القصف في تلك الفوضى
اضطر ديما إلى دفن والده بنفسه
وولدت غرفة الطوارئ الأجنبية وحيث  قد
تضرب النيران مرة أخرى
كل منزل أوكراني تقريبًا به ثقوب
من أشخاص لن يعودوا،
ومشاعر تتشكل في حرب لا نهاية لها في
الأفق،
هو
أجنبي
نيك بايتون والش، سي إن إن زاباريزيو أوكرانيا